I have a question I have a question so
are we guys so so when you when you're
looking for wifey are you going to use
this system and just get rid of the
ghosts we'll be the same system
you wouldn't fall for this system no she
absolutely would because he's I'm
awesome bro like yeah yeah
okay wait let me answer the question
I mean I'd have to see someone I think
is wifey so I guess at the moment it's
kind of like if we get through these
stages and I think you're cool and you
show enough qualities loyalty
um you're intelligent you know you've
got all my long-term qualities then yeah
and that almost happened once yeah
Cambridge go
um super intelligent but she was a
feminist so I had to dump her but
could you not tell that like like a
little bit earlier on that actually this
one could be a good girl I make no
assumptions in these hoes
she could be a professional girl she
could do anything hoes have so many
strategies women strategies are way more
sophisticated
yeah I just understand you guys
I don't think you understand I think
you're full for this
um so yeah I think I think it's
generally just what it is because it's
based on my experiences and the reality
if you give someone too much attention
and they're too consistent early on you
look bad it's true if you if you're too
kind of easy to understand
um you look bad they get bored it's not
interesting if you cannot flip between
the Alpha and the beta if you're too
dominant and you show no signs of
weakness actually yeah I've got a
question what is what is what is
flipping into the Beta in that point to
in your eyes it's just pretending you
need this woman like you know like she
has um just pretending that like you're
looking for some kind of emotional
connection because most women look for
validation attention constantly it's
like it's like they prefer to food
sometimes right so correction all
[ __ ] women look for attention and
validation literally their lifebloods
you've got to know how to manage that
right if I was the alpha dominant animal
you know I am right I won't I don't
actually need someone like that I got a
good job I've got good friends I don't
need I don't go to clubs and think oh
wow this girl's got a nice house I need
her I'm gonna text her all night until
she no I don't think that that's to make
her I think that is wouldn't you say
that I I got what you're saying but
wouldn't you say like if you've got a
girl and she knows other girls that have
been with you or they she she knows
other girls with the guy right so she
almost feels like the attention that he
gives you almost might have to earn it
because he's spreading it other people
no that's just a recipe for trouble
because what you're going to do is
you're going to develop a bad reputation
women will create drama and I have a job
that's too good for that I can't I can't
wake up stress is that what is in the
salsa in the salsa world so there's also
the dance world and everything but in
the salsa world you just learn quicker
because you know you see everything in a
much shorter time frame the girls come
in they go for the same guys you know
he's a sexy salsa guy he texts everyone
say oh you want to come meet me at this
bar and actually it's invite you to his
class because he's a teacher you're
going to sit there be impressed by the
attention he's getting eventually you
should shock this guy because I'm not
gonna hustle for you because I'm
probably in the class or just chilling
in the social or something
um after that you know you're gonna he's
a good looking guy right he's probably
got a decent job he's a good dancer
everything's great you're going to want
to kind of extend that sexual thing he's
not going to do that because he shocks
everyone then you're gonna come to me
right now you want something deeper
because anyone could [ __ ] you now you
realize I was the man the whole time and
obviously you've kind of passed my shelf
shelf kind of Life by then so but that's
different though so if you met a woman
that you're seeing her in a second like
a specific circumstance do I mean like I
get why you look at her that way 100
because you watch to do that but for
example if you met a woman completely
random at a coffee shop random place
like you can't then judge her off of
that like one place because you don't
know her that was your first meeting she
could have been very polite very well
educated very well job very attractive
where'd you sit then I would still run
this exact process in fact those women
are the most the most vulnerable to this
because they're basically like left-wing
grooming but don't you think the other
women are more vulnerable because those
are the ones that are emotionally
unstable because they just whip with a
man and realize they ain't getting
vulnerable like like we stop it like we
act like women or children like you're a
grown adult you're not vulnerable I love
how like because I figured out the game
I'm an animal like you know what this
this took years of having your time
wasted and being disrespected and over
investing like until you figure out why
this happens I just refuse to believe
women are super vulnerable and don't
know what they're doing
obviously people know people are not
dumb but I say that there's people that
live in reality and a dream world and
people don't like face in the reality so
they act dumb and act naive it's only
people that actually know themselves
they're actually like yeah I know what
I'm doing but most of the time people
pretend like they don't and they try to
make themselves believe that and that's
my point of being vulnerable like you're
You're vulnerable but obviously you know
what you're doing yeah but that's my
meaning when I'm speaking yeah I
understand but I think I think he's
saying like he he'll find his wife
through this system too he just won't
ghost here he'll take out stuff for it
well take her out like at this point you
have you have so many opportunities to
assure me that you're you're kind of
something better than I would have
imagined but by date three has she had
to have given it up
um yeah yeah I'm not I'm saying on that
to be honest to be honest I I don't need
to do more than like
two days like if if one day is my Max
but if if like there's like there's a
good reason right and after the date
she's like you know I can't play Because
you know I'm on my Reds or you know I
just don't do it on the first day all
right fine you get a second date second
date nothing then it's like all right
now you have to take me out or you know
there has to be something because guys
realize that this is all my time and
energy like yeah I understand that some
females watching this may have convinced
themselves that they're actually victims
of of this but I've actually spent my
time and energy without any real return
but the plus 99 of this process so
actually you're kind of winning the only
the only way you're not winning is that
you actually like me because I'm dope so
that's what you're losing is that you're
gonna feel you lost someone valuable
because you did lose someone so when I
asked you earlier that by like at the
end of it she needs to have given you
sex and you said you're not too sure Buy
Date three if she hasn't given it up so
then you are saying you should be seeing
six at least no I don't say should these
are like kind of words is it are they
verbs or something should conditional
verbs that just don't exist in my world
right so in other words do you expect
sex at the end of it or you [ __ ] off of
course I expect such to them do you see
this
we're not expecting it all right so you
should you
synonymous here no there's no shirt
should it's about what someone else
should do I can't tell her what she
should do I I can only invest my time
and energy with a certain intention and
if that doesn't work out then I I simply
messages I have a question what if what
if she says three months oh [ __ ] up
someone did that someone did that right
you respond a ton of money yeah yeah
someone someone did that so there was
one girl that said like three months so
she was like um a dancer she was really
cute we went on like two dates so I was
like damn I'm really doing the most view
B but you can make this worth it
um and basically the end you're going
for like I think
no it was third base or home run or
whatever and she said she made some kind
of excuse she was like oh I take my time
to get to know people just that and so I
never spoke to her again and she turned
up like a month ago and was like trying
to get my number talk to me see these
girls just don't know what they have and
a lot of women their strategy is I'm not
gonna filter for men I'm just gonna let
everyone in and see you give me the most
time and attention and I would take it
step further and say that women what
they say they want and what they
actually want in real life are too
completely listen to women
do you think this was developed by women
all women even my my most rational
female friends will say stuff like I
want a guy who's nice who's honest she
forgets that she's also telling me why
she doesn't like the nice honest guys on
our other conversations see a
conversation with women is just an
exercise and cerebral stimulation
you're trying to like you know touch on
as many things as possible make her feel
excited attach certain buttons yeah
there's no point there's not an end men
we will talk with a point in it there's
like an actual subject and an end goal
women talk in an explorative way it's
like improvisation in jazz right if you
understand that you understand women
like when they say they want a guy who's
chat and he's got this they just want a
guy who can kind of stimulate them in
that way without making them feel like
they need to put something on the table
you still do
but I'm just not going to make you feel
like that you should know that because I
expect you to be smart and that's what
we call getting attention and validation
yeah well if you're not smart I just
stop in it and trust me they'll notice
one you stopping it because they're
probably getting hit on by bums probably
giving their time and attention to guys
that are way less than you because those
are people who win it's not it's not
guys like me who get the most it's guys
who just try the hardest unemployed guys
get the most ass out of anyone I promise
you that there's no limits
there's no look some of you guys in the
comments are like oh you know you have
to be six foot shut up you loser listen
the guys who are getting the most ass in
London are five foot two Spanish guys
there was no like oh you have to look
like Brad Pitt no no no
I can show you some dudes out there but
they're texting everyone they're doing
the most thing
I love you see we should go dancing
together we can be a team he says that
to everyone and they all believe it
because they're 22. it's a numbers game
yes
but this is like my level stuff so you
got to be kind of like reclusive you've
got to pick people you want to engage
with because I think to me sex is like a
mutually she's a value I'm a value so in
my relationships
um I don't have relationships but in my
roster there's like a there's like this
mutual respect so you could think of me
as a pimp but I'm not really a pimp
because I'm not really pulling into
anything over anyone's eyes they know
what's up and I expect them to be clever
and respectful and if anything as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible